ich war gestern bei der pressekonferenz
dabei ich muss sagen ich mir jetzt auch
schon etwas länger reporter aber als
dann berichtet wurde dass der der
staatsanwalt hatte das berichtet das in
dem haus hier eine frühstück situation
so hieß es vorgefunden wurde mit fünf
schildchen 55 tellern und fünf messer
gabeln und fünf toten kindern in ihren
kindern betten gefunden wurde muss ich
sagen das ist auch mir anders geworden
und so geht es auch hier den leuten
nicht drehe mich mal einmal um da kann
er fest immer einmal drauf gehen wir
sehen hier ein meer von kerzen ein meer
von blumen haben ganz ganz kleine kinder
ihre beschützer hingelegt stofftiere
haben was gemalt haben was geschrieben
so dass die kleinkinder oben im himmel
nicht alleine sind und man muss sagen
das ist wirklich ein sehr trauriges bild
das wetter spielt hier heute auch nicht
so richtig mit ich habe gerade mit sehr
vielen bewohnern hier aus dem aus dem
haus gesprochen und auch die sind
ehrlich gesagt maximal überfordert mit
der ganzen situation in dem haus sind
fünf kinder gestorben man kann dass sich
die kleinkinder haben mit den mit den
mit den verstorbenen und betonten
getöteten kindern gespielt und das ist
wirklich für alle hier unfassbar an der
eingangstür zum haus ist noch ein aufruf
heute 19 uhr für eine große lichterkette
und wir haben auch mit einem mit einem
herrn gesprochen der auch hier eine eine
kerze gerade niedergelegt hat dass es
benjamin braatz er bereits erzählen sie
uns ein bisschen wie haben sie davon
erfahren sie kommen ja ein bisschen
weiter weg
warum fasst sie das auch an obwohl sie
weiter weg wollen ja so ist es sowas
geht natürlich an einem nicht vorbei ich
komme aus wuppertal und wir haben das
mitgekriegt und da bleibt natürlich auch
einem erstmal die spucke weg
es ist sowas zum traurig fünf kinder
ja warum so früh ja also da hätte man
vielleicht besser reagieren können
es ist einfach sehr traurig mache mir
jetzt eigentlich so gar nicht was man
sagen sie dazu mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schau dich
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren